[Music]
welcome everyone to this
lockdown edition of the madness of
quantum reality
uh thanks for all coming along um i i
i can only appreciate you as virtual
participants
in this extravaganza who will hopefully
stay with me for the next
40 or 45 minutes not quite sure which
um in an ambitious attempt i think uh
not to just explain um some of the
bizarre things
that quantum mechanics has to say about
the nature of reality
but my main ambition really is to try
and
explain why why quantum mechanics
has these characteristics and what we're
going to do is we're going to take
a very quick run-through of the history
of physics from the
turn of the 19th century onwards i want
to just establish a few principles about
what mechanics
is about the motions of particles and
waves and how these came together in
quantum mechanics
and hopefully by the end as i say you'll
have understanding of why quantum
mechanics
is as not only obscure but as crazy as
it seems
we're going to begin by taking a look at
the science of mechanics at the turn of
the 19th century so around 1900
uh physicists in those days had really
two
uh ways of looking at mechanics
mechanics is simply the science of
of motion stuff that moves and
there were really two uh sets of
theories
uh that were really um
refined by a time really well understood
the motions of objects a bouncing ball a
cannonball
a grain of sand a planet a star
all objects material objects were
thought to be explained
quite adequately uh by these mechanical
laws
newton's three laws of motion but there
was another kind of motion that required
a different set of principles and a
different set of
equations and that's obviously the
motion of waves
described by a wave equation which looks
something like this
what's interesting to note about this
pattern is that the wave appears to be
moving from left to right but the
individual points in the wave are
actually only moving
up and down as you can see if you just
with your eye trace the motions of those
red dots
and this kind of description was thought
to apply obviously to all kinds of waves
but also including the phenomenon of
light
so we had one set of equations to
describe the motions of
objects and we had one set of equations
to describe the motions of waves
now one of the reasons why
physicists believed that these
equations of wave motion applied to
light
were through things that had been
discovered
in physics already uh almost a century
before so in the early 19th century the
notion of something called two-slit
interference was quite well established
this is where we take a a wave these
these vertical lines coming up from the
left
uh are intended to give the impression
of wave fronts so imagine
if you were stood on a beach and these
waves were pulling in gently
um onto the uh the front of the beach
um these waves are then forced to
squeeze through two
narrow boops or slits uh cut in uh
and out of that uh because they're
forced to squeeze they
they undergo something called
diffraction and when they diffract
we end up with two sets of circular
expanding waves which then
overlap and interfere um the result as
you can see on the right is a
is a pattern because this is light um
what we end up with is a pattern of
alternating
bright and dark fringes this is called
an interference pattern
and effectively what it means is that
the waves are combining and where they
overlap in a way that
gives rise to a big peak that's called
constructive interference and where the
waves
uh combine together both in a trough
that gives rise to a deeper trough
and where they uh coincide with peak
and trough they get cancelled out and
the result is a dark fringe
and that was all fine so you had one set
of equations to describe the motions of
objects you had another set of equations
to describe
the motions of waves um but then in 1905
um depending on your point of view you
could say things started to go horribly
wrong
when albert einstein revealed one of
nature's
dirty little secrets in a paper he
published in 1905 he speculated
um monochromatic radiation simply means
light of of a single color blue light or
green light
and he suggested it behaves as though
the radiation
were a discontinuous medium consisting
of energy quantum let me translate that
for
what he's really saying is that light
waves
can be particles today we know those
particles as
photons so what einstein was doing
already in 1905 was saying
don't forget all about the wave
description of light because we needed
to
explain things like diffraction and
interference
there are circumstances in which it's
perhaps
wise or best to think of light waves in
terms of
of quant in terms of particles photons
then things got messed up really
seriously by
one of my heroes of this period of
physics
louis de broy in 1923 suddenly had the
idea that the discovery made by einstein
in 1905 should be generalized by
extending it to all material particles
and
no two electrons
electrons are those things negatively
charged particles that circulate around
the nuclei of atoms
we know about electrons every time you
plug something into the mains
electricity you got a flow of electrons
which means that stuff in your kitchen
works or your tv works or whatever
and we tend to think of electrons as
small contained objects
we can't really picture them very well
because they're very very small and we
can't see them
but we tend to think of them as small
bundles
bits of charged matter electrically
charged matter
but what de broglie was saying in 1923
is actually hang on
maybe electrons can be waves and this is
one depiction here of a electron wave
formed around the nucleus of an atom
well this is all starting to get a
little bit bizarre um
uh it begs all sorts of difficult
questions so for example if
we can see light diffraction and
interference in a two-slit
experiment and if as suggests
electric wave and can we do the two-slit
experiment with electrons
and and what then happens if we do the
experiment where we pass
the electrons through the slits
one at a time now over on the left of
this picture
um older viewers will know that in the
early days of tv
tvs work by having a cathode ray gun
at the back of the set which would
produce a beam of electrons cathode rays
as they were
known in the early days which would
spray over a phosphor screen
and the image would be translated into
pointing the electrons in different
places on the screen
to form and shape an image but we can
take that
electron gun that cathode ray gun and
use it as a source
of electrons in an electron beam but we
turn the intensity of that beam down
such that on average there's only one
electron
passing through the two slits at a time
what what would we expect to see
now logic would suggest that if these
electrons really are
tiny little bits of charged material
substance
then the electron goes through one or
the other of the two slits and we end up
with
two bright lines forming on the screen
beyond
these are shown here by the blue curves
we form one
peak on the left and one peak on the
right but if electrons
really are like waves then we might
expect something different
maybe something that looks like the
brown
curve in this particular picture which
is the
interference pattern now before we start
asking ourselves
disturbing questions about how we could
expect an electron
to be forming an interference pattern
all by itself
let's just have a a look at to see what
actually happens and this is what i tend
to think of as the essential mystery of
quantum mechanics so here's what happens
we begin the process we start to observe
and this is kind of reassuring we see
little points of light where the
electrons are striking the screen
and as more and more electrons come
through
uh we start to see these seem to be
scattering randomly
but by the time we're done
now it's not very high resolution but
you can begin to see that what we
certainly
don't see is two lines
or groups where the electrons have gone
through either one slit or the other
what we have here is an
interference pattern so even though the
electrons are passing through the two
slits
one at a time on average uh we still get
an interference plan
and that's fundamentally disturbing
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas